I can like walk out of a photo shoot
with like a hundred people working on
set I can walk out like in a thong but
if it's like you're there with me I'm
like wait
Kim Kardashian reveals she's a lights
off in the bedroom kind of gal yeah
Bible the kkw beauty founder made the
candid confession on the latest episode
of Hulu's the Kardashians during a chat
with Scott Disick about her dating life
I pretty much have the lights off now
lights off kind of girl
is that kind of
yeah it's so weird but then I can like
walk out of a photo shoot with like a
hundred people working on set I can walk
out like in a thong but if it's like
you're there with me I'm like turn the
lights off of course Kim and her ex
Kanye West finalized their divorce last
November after six years of marriage and
following their split she dated Pete
Davidson he's just super genuine I love
the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet I thought you
said the chemistry I was like okay
chemistry chemistry but the two called
it quits in August after nine months of
dating and while she didn't name names
she seemingly referenced their time
together saying she learned a lot from
the experience the one thing I learned
from my last situation was like the
media made me feel like I was in like a
very like
serious relationship like so quickly I
just want to sneak around a little bit
like there's nothing wrong with wanting
to sneak all that Echoes What A source
told E.T last month about Kim's attitude
towards finding love again she's laid
back about dating is in no rush to meet
someone and is comfortable being single
Kim's just living her best life and
isn't taking herself too seriously I
swear I'm really good she has amazing
energy right now and everyone around her
loves it and that energy was on full
display as Kim hinted at a mystery man
she's casually seeing so I'm not even
going to ask you who so let's call this
guy
Fred does he meet the standards oh so
meets the standards meets the standards
yeah
it's a lot of smiling
you know is that Fred yeah
two years what
no I'm going to be
I'm going to be
and while we'll just have to wait and
see if Fred's true identity is ever
revealed we just love seeing Kim having
fun you just gotta roll with it
[Music]